authier contamine journal le cadeau que
nous offre france roche et nos cameramen
tout sur la mode la mode de l'édition 18
bien sûr figurez vous que pendant une
semaine entière pour 2000 privilégier
les couturiers vont présenter trois
mines robe qui valent 100 millions 1
milliard de centimes alors bien sûr vous
allez me dire c'est beaucoup d'honneur
pour seulement de 4000 clients en france
et dans le monde
eh bien je serais tenter de vous
répondre toujours à l'aide de
statistiques que cela fait vivre
trente mille personnes et que le chiffre
d'affaires est de 3 milliards et demi
c'est à dire le cinquième de la
sidérurgie
etonnant non alors fini de parler
chiffres maintenant parlons chiffon et
puis surtout regarde et écoute on france
roche pour la petite dame qui vit le nez
en l'air perchée sur des talons
voici le tailleur de ferro toute rayure
en hauteur et puis bien plat
celui de torrents habasque courte et
cols sages canotiers dans le vent celui
de balmain dos décolleté egypte français
celui de chanel qu'on porte un gilet de
collégiens anglais et une cravate
western pour le petit l'ordre de jean
louis ferrer encore plus anglais cannes
et melon pour le soir les écharpe
fleurie de chanel
tu
le pantalon surprise de patou qui
dénouerait devient unique et la tunique
biblique de cardin inscrits dans un
losange pour celle qui domine toutes les
situations romantisme exaspéré avec la
robe d'agip dansante devenait la manche
compliqué le corsage drapé de 30 à elle
la robe dit émotionnel de ferro tout
froufrous et transparence
la robe lingerie devenait comporte la
même émotion as une robe ou une chemise
de nuit
hélas les dés de jean luchaire avec
basque aumônière semble fait pour une
présentation à la cour
sultane brodé à trois étages par
givenchy
les falbalas violet de tarente semble
fait pour une comtesse de m'offrir
mieux' est toujours balzacienne se
lisent dans la vallée que fleury lapidus
enfin les jeux de longueur la robe cap
de pas tout
la robe duplex de balmain et la mini
longue de scapa rallye enfin pour celles
qui possèdent abondance de charme
c'est la joie ampleur partout avec les
manteaux devenait exotiques ou de style
monacale dans ce tailleur de lapidus on
peut loger facilement une dame et demi
le tailleur de dior avec fermeture nous
et et jus boutonnet absorbe tous les
surplus
une autre trouvaille de dior la taille
plongeante devant pour estomac pas très
plat taille encore plus basse chez guy
laroche avec ça on peut déjeuner
tranquille même confort chez perspect
avec ses manches oiseaux de schiaparelli
on peut donner de l'envol un éléphant
dans la robe santana et maury on peut
loger des jumeaux et dans ce tailleur de
balmain des quintuplés sans effort
avec la robe bébé de carven pas de
bourdes là ni à la ville ni à la plage
enfin le soir en trompe l'oeil on peut
tout caché sous ses bosses line ou tout
montrer
ainsi que dans ceux parle qui n'a de la
roche
et dans cette robe abat-jour de ninard
xxi
avec tout ça on portera des chaussures
lacées au pied et sur la tête des
boucles serrées que maurice francs que
veut appeler pour sa ligne
charlot et cinéma muet même boucle dans
la ligne bonsaï échevelé de lucie
sinclair ou écologiques comme
l'artichaut de michel maes tu es avec
colliers assorti de mini artichauts
enfin grand choix de pantalon loose ans
chez lanvin et resserré en bas indien
drapée aux chevilles chez hanae mori
vague sherer serré chez schiaparelli
fendue au chili chez cardin
en pleine inflation chez perse book
enfin pour celles qui aiment se faire
remarquer 50 m de ficelle et 5 kg de
perles de bois pour copier cette robe
courants d'air de paco rabanne
l'année prochaine on peut en faire un
rideau andy mouche qui disait que la
haute couture n'était pas pratique
moi j'ai la coiffure un peu écologie